Let's first get started and our index at
HTML
And let's go ahead and add the adventuresOf
the code Works Crusader here.
The next thing we need to take care of is we
don't know longer going to be working with
this intro.jsWe need to create another file
here.
And we're going to name this file our
main.js
I'm going to want to get rid of this intro
cuz we're going to actually create a whole
new file for all the JavaScript we're going
to have for the adventures of the codework
Crusader
So let's do the same thing we did earlier
with the intro let's just log hello from
main.js here
And let's make sure we actually get that
loaded up onto our screen
Dang itOh Lord. Stop it.
Got to keep remembering f11Fabriccons I
don't care about favicons.
So it's refresh this page and we actually
get that hello from main.js
So at this point we know that our JavaScript
is linked up with our web application or Dom
So let's now get rid of this hello world
header and we'll start adding some of the
items we
need in there we're just going to kind of
add them in like our old low Fidelity
mockLike we made last.
So I'm going to start by kind of Destruction
is almost like our low Fidelity mock from
our figma lecture
And just get a lot of the items on the
screen that I want to work withAnd just get
the functionality this application working
first and then at the end we'll.
go ahead and style it up to actually make it
look like that final product
So let's head back to our index.html
Okay yeah I'll sing that about replacing
that fabric on butI won't worry about it for
now it doesn't matter.
So let's go ahead and just delete this H1
here we don't need that guy
We'll go ahead and add in our
Oh man I didn't do it the way I would
normally would over here
So I'll go ahead and start with my mainI
won't be using a header tag here.
Just because of the structure of this
application and then I'm going to start with
a section tag
And then in that section tag we're going to
make sure weMake it a container fluid.
And now I want to just quickly set up well
dang it get too far into styling
I'll be backWell now let me give you one
thing oh my goodness.
I'm going to quit create a quick row here
cuz I need somewhere to put the two health
bars and then I'll do a couple call six here
so we're going to do two call six
I'm home I'm talking like a spazSo I'm going
to make two column sixes here.
And we can do that by doing call Dash 6 and
we can just do times two
And this first call is going to represent
the hero
And this next call six is going to represent
the villain
And we're going to keep this simple for nowI
want to create some sort of.
Header for this so I like to create Rose so
I'm going to do another row here
And then I'm going to do a call 12 for now
And I just want to create a P tagAnd this is
going to be my heroes.
HealthAnd then we'll start at zero.
We can go ahead and just copy thisAnd we'll
move this down to our villain.
Instead of hear yourself we'll just change
it to villain's health
We'll just start at 100 for bothCool.
And after this I'm going to want to create a
button
So it's going to be in its own different row
underneath of it for nowThis is going to be
a.
Call three and let's go ahead and just use
our button classAnd we will say attack.
Our button will just say type buttonWe'll
just give it a class of B10 BTN. Outline for
now.
Great so let's go check this out at our web
application see what it looks like
He looks really good huh
So right now we got ourTwo Health at the top
and our attack I'm going to go ahead and
give that top row of some.
Padding just so we can get some breathing
room from the top of the pageSo let's go
ahead and just give this a.
Padding top five for now
Let's actually just make this a container as
well so we can get some of the gutters on
the side
SweetAwesome so this looks a little bit
easier to work with.
I'll do the same thing here I'm just going
to give this someI'll give it actually a
little bit of Marge on the top and we'll
just justify.
ContentContent Center as well.
I don't actually like the will do outline
Dart So It Isn't So blending in so muchSo
great.
We have the foundation of how we want this
project to be started withCuz the idea now
is I have my health.
For my hero in my villain and I also have
this button to attack
So now we need to go into JavaScript
actually create some variablesOr an object.
And then set those variables to actually be
able to input inside our HTML so inside our
DomSo let's go try that out.
I don't so let's go try that out question
mark
So let's go actually start so let's go
actually
So let's go create those objects in our
JavaScript and get that scripted into our
DomSure.